Kristof let me ask you why do you think
that Truman has never come close to
discovering the true nature of his world
until now we accept the reality of the
world with which we're presented it's as
simple as then in the beginning of the
Truman Show a star falls from the sky
well a light falls from the ceiling of a
sky high set that encloses an artificial
town built for the life of one man and
the entertainment of the whole world the
light says Sirius 9 Canis Major which
refers to Sirius the brightest star in
the night sky this star which Homer once
called an evil portent bringing heat and
fevers to suffering humanity in the film
the falling of Sirius is the first in a
series of ruptures in Truman's fake
reality a series that ends here with an
actual rupture a breach in things as
they are like an Homer Peter Weir
director of The Truman Show envisions
this door into real reality in darker
terms than you might expect all the
symbols we usually associate with
goodness and positivity are behind
Truman bright blue skies sunbeams
breaking through the clouds an expanse
of sea of possibility reality truth and
authenticity on the other hand are
relegated to a small single rectangle of
shadow hardly the light at the end of
the tunnel that we normally associate
with liberation all throughout the film
freedom for Truman is linked tightly
with trauma every peek behind the
curtain is accompanied by some form of
pain whether it's the pain of seeing the
image of a deceased loved one the pain
of a true connection abruptly cut short
the pain of memory or simply the pain of
uncertainty of not knowing what it is
you're seeing that's of course a pain
that we're all familiar with it's why
for the most part we see only what we
want to see Truman has been privy to a
lifetime full of hints clues to the fact
that his world is not as it seems
yes to incorporate those clues means to
reconfigure the entire narrative of his
existence and rewrites like that just
aren't free they cost
they cost suffering Peter Weir and
writer Andrew Niccol were prophetic
about so much from the Vantage of 1998
the ubiquity of reality television the
rise of mass surveillance they keyed in
perfectly to my parents generation of
Cold War paranoia of being watched or
bugged and my own generation of
narcissism where it bugs us not to be
watched that's a great joy of The Truman
Show the allegories and layered readings
the heaviness of it all stands out
vividly even for a kid like I was when I
saw it at age 10 it's not pedantic or
preachy it just asks so many damn
questions that they're impossible to
ignore are you talking about
who are you talking to and actually I
was watching it again recently and I was
really struck by how easily The Truman
Show can be read as an allegory for the
present like Truman's town of Seahaven
our own world seems to be experiencing a
similar series of ruptures ruptures like
the Great Recession in 2008 the Arab
Spring like the killings of young black
men by police or our increasing
awareness of them like brexit the
splitting of the UK from Europe and most
recently like the rise of the political
outsider movements of Bernie Sanders and
Donald Trump I think American society at
large is a lot like Truman Burbank
laboring like him for 30 plus years
under a system that is finally showing
itself to be ridiculous society like
Truman is trying to wake itself up while
stumbling under the pain that surfaces
from doing so The Truman Show is a
massive operation with a crew and cast
of thousands but for all the power that
Christoph commands the show's success
always hinges on Truman himself and can
only work if Truman believes in it he
could leave at any time she was
absolutely determined to discover the
truth there's no way we could prevent
him the powerful in our world hold
things in place like Christophe holds
but we hold ourselves in place too if
nothing else it's clear that in 2016 we
are slowly waking up into a new
political reality like in Truman's world
the power relationships of our own have
gained and consolidated strength by
convincing us that they're normal
like laws of nature by taking any breach
and folding it back into the narrative
they've kept all those like Truman who
are perennial losers at bay but
ideologies don't last forever eventually
they crumble under their own weight and
the increasing refusal of people to
believe in thank you for your help
you're welcome true
The Truman Show shows us what waking up
looks like it stages in a really
valuable way the struggles that come
with it it shows how the messaging of
the dominant ideology is absorbed into
media and into education it shows us how
individual people even people we trust
good people can become the mouthpieces
of a rotten system everybody is in on it
I'd have to be enough to and most
importantly evolve The Truman Show
imagines liberation not as utopia but as
a world flawed like our own full of
multiplicity and contradiction and
people obsessed with TV it's a world
gained only by struggle and paint one
that often looks like an evil portent in
the moment it's not a sunburst in the
clouds or an endless sea but a small
shadowy door that leads off to a
territory unmapped but invested
hopefully with a greater authenticity in
case I don't say yeah good afternoon
good evening and good night
[Music]
[Applause]
there is a new nerdwriter video every
wednesday so if you go right there and
click on that you'll subscribe to this
channel get all the videos and that's
what helps me out the most the truman
show blows my mind every time I watch it
I saw it in the theaters when I was 10
in 1998 with my mom and it was one of
the best movie experiences the formative
movie experiences of my life so this was
a blast to make thanks so much for
watching again I'll see you guys next
Wednesday